hello everybody markiplier here and we
just hit seventy thousand subscribers
which is unbelievable I mean I I can't
even understand how it's happening or
why or what I'm doing more you know
anything like that so thank you guys so
much for helping the channel grow so
quickly I mean if you if you haven't
been following we've been getting about
a thousand subscribers a day plus or
minus for the past few weeks and that's
not an exaggeration because we were just
at fifty thousand two weeks ago and I
mean three I didn't even know it wasn't
that long ago and we were at fifty
thousand and just to be at this number
right now is unbelievable to me I can't
understand how or why and in a lot of
ways you know I I think you know it hits
me in waves at how many people watch my
videos and in a lot of ways I feel like
I don't deserve the kind of attention
that I'm getting because there are a lot
of really cool channels out there that
are very creative and actually make
interesting stuff because well at the
end of the day I I just play video games
and that's all I do and that's that's
just you know it's kind of pathetic in a
way I don't contribute anything and I
don't feel like what I do is good enough
to deserve the kind of attention that
I've been getting you know I want to
push myself to do more and I hope that
you know in a lot of ways so long as I
keep the attitude that I always need to
push myself to do something more and
better that I'm always gonna improve and
stay grounded but you know with with
approaching actually by the time this
video is released I wouldn't be
surprised if we were at seventy one
thousand because seventy thousand happen
yesterday and I wasn't able to make a V
log but still it's it's hard to
comprehend exactly what's going on with
the channel because I've long since
passed the point where I could keep up
with messages I've got about fifteen
hundred messages sitting in my youtube
inbox I can't I can't look at those I've
completely abandon all attempts to read
Facebook messages unless something
catches my eye because I've got hundreds
and hundreds of pending messages there
if you want to contact me the best way
is probably going to be email
right me and evil because that's I can
search through it I can see how many
I've got left I keep up with my email
regularly so if you have a question and
want to tell me something send me
something in markiplier at gmail.com but
it's just I miss I missed the times when
I could talk with everyone on a personal
basis because no matter what happens and
no matter how hard I try when you guys
look at me through the screen like I'm
just one guy sitting on this end of my
screen and there's seven over seventy
thousand people on the other side of
mine and I III can't keep up with and I
think back to the times when I was first
starting out and I was speaking with
people on a regular basis and I almost
felt like you know I could I could be
the kind of person that communicates
with everyone that makes everyone to
feel special and I told myself a
thousand times that I'd never lose track
of that and then I never realized that
people people don't choose to lose track
of it people don't they literally can't
it's it's impossible and it's
frustrating and it it's really like
aggravating that I can't do it anymore
and I want to I want to really badly
because I do care and no matter what I
do people are gonna start thinking that
I don't care and that's not true the
only the only thing that I do is I care
more and there's been some recent things
that happen with them people
communicating with my channel and stuff
and I I want to be able to reach out to
them and tell them that I am trying to
pay attention and I wanted to do more to
make sure that that's heard like you
guys are exceptionally important to me
and this channel is exceptionally
important to me and what we're building
is of the utmost importance to the
Future community that I'm leading this
little ragtag team of
people have started to balloon into this
big channel than people are I don't know
if people are calling me names I'm not
bad names I mean like people are saying
that woo got a new youtuber and stuff
like that and I mean like I'm just a guy
you know my name is mark I I'm a guy who
goes to school I you know I've had quite
a few jobs before this and you know I
haven't really done anything special but
still we've come a long way in a short
amount of time and it's hard to keep up
with it so just think know that I'm
always grateful always grateful for the
things that you guys have done to me how
you've changed my life and shaped what
I'm gonna do in the future and I want
you guys to always know even if I don't
come up with these real augs enough I
want you guys to always know that I am
constantly thinking about how I can
improve myself in the channel what I can
do for the betterment of society and
what I can do to help out because
there's a lot of people that I want to
help and there's a lot of people that I
couldn't help before this and suddenly
I'm able to so I want to be able to do
more and I hope that you will join me as
I want to do
thank you guys for 70,000 subscribers
and I wouldn't be surprised if in the
next month we would hit a hundred
thousand thank you for everything I'm
not going to give up
thank you all so much for watching sorry
I tend to ramble on about things that
don't even matter so thank you guys for
watching me and I will commit myself to
coming out with more high quality videos
for you every single day so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]